laure monnaie universelle de la richesse
et du pouvoir
pierre angulaire des grands empires
le minéral qui a changé le cours de
l'histoire l' aventure de l'or et de
l'argent est une odyssée qui s'étend sur
six mille ans et touche cinq continents
les canaux de venise au terrain aurifère
de californie
les routes commerciales asiatique au
building de wall street
une saga qui accompagne l'essor de notre
civilisation en 3000 avant jésus-christ
l'or fait déjà office de monnaie
rudimentaire
on est alors dans les premiers
balbutiements de la notion d'une devise
le paiement des biens et des services
s'effectue par le troc de tout objet
digne de valeur y compris les épices la
nourriture et les animaux d'élevage
si le principe des changes existe depuis
des milliers d'années
il trouve cependant rapidement ses
limites on imagine mal à marchand avec
un portefeuille rempli de moutons
il faut trouver une méthode plus
pratique la solution apparaît aux
alentours de l'an 600 avant jésus christ
hassar 10 capitale de la libye
l'un des plus riches royaumes de
l'antiquité
à cheval au carrefour de trois
continents sarr 10 voix aussi bien
passer des armes et que des caravanes
soldats et marchands finissent par
s'embarrasser de devoir transporter les
marchandises volumineuses qu'ils
échangent il est bien difficile de payer
sous forme de biens des soldats qui
passent leur temps à combattre
il faut donc créer quelque chose qui est
à la fois de la valeur et qu'on puisse
emmener avec soi facile la solution
repose est insolente dans le lit de la
rivière pactole us à sare 10 des pépites
d'or rouler par le courant depuis les
collines alentours
et c'est vers 550 avant jésus-christ le
roi crésus de lydie peut-être lui-même
légendaire roi midas a eu le premier
l'idée de créer une pièce d'or
[Musique]
elle ça en est il ne s'agissait pas
seulement de battre la monnaie mais en
même temps de lui conférer une valeur le
roi se portait en quelque sorte garant
de cette valeur
si avec ses pièces vous ne pouviez plus
tout à coup vous acheter par exemple dit
peau de mouton
le roi lui vous garantissez la
transaction sept petits disques de métal
jaune vont littéralement changé le cours
de l'histoire
c'était simplement un moyen plus
efficace de transférer des richesses
d'un propriétaire à un autre haut lieu
que je vous donne deux chameaux pour
votre poudre à canon
il devenait bien plus pratique que je
vous la paie en monnaie
si à travers les époques d'autres
minéraux comme l'argenson également
frappé sous forme de pièces l'or demeure
le plus précieux des métaux
à travers l'histoire des civilisations
l'or a toujours été un critère de valeur
il ne connaît aucune barrière
international religieuse de langage une
once d'or reste une once d'or que ce
soit en chine aux états unis en russie
en afrique du sud ou dans le san
francisco de la ruée vers l'or devenu
monnaie courante dans tout le bassin
méditerranéen
les pièces d'or de sart 10 tisse un lien
historique entre est et ouest
elles sont la première devise accepté
dans le commerce des soie et des épices
asiatique des marchandises alors très
prisé alors un rapport valeur poids très
élevé c'est à dire par exemple qu'on
peut transporter sur soi une valeur
importante sous la forme de petites
pièces le relativement légère on a
trouvé la forme idéale pour une monnaie
et c'est pour ça qu'elle est restée en
vigueur pendant des milliers d'années
cette simple forme de transaction fixe
la norme des échanges internationaux
pour les 2500 ans qui suivent
de la même manière qu'elle pose les
fondations de notre économie
alors que la pratique consistant à
battre la monnaie s'étend à travers
l'europe et l'asie
l'or devient espèces sonnantes et
trébuchantes des royaumes alexandre le
grand rémunère ses armées en pièces d'or
les romains s'appuie sur l'or pour
édifier le plus grand empire que le
monde ait connu si quelqu'un à rome
souhaitait faire du commerce avec une
autre personne
ailleurs dans le monde on pouvait
acheminer 2 lors d'un pays à l'autre
c'est à dire que la valeur transférés
demeurée la même
où qu'elle se trouve un engagement
financier avait valeur permanente
c'est pour cela que l'or s'est répandue
devenu officiellement mener des changes
leur incarne en quelque sorte la pierre
angulaire des civilisations à la chute
de l'empiré romain occidental en 476
après jésus-christ ses mines d'or 16
tout simplement leur production sans or
le commerce qui alimentait le
développement de la civilisation dans ce
qui figure aujourd'hui notre europe
occidentale s'est arrêté une fois que l'
empire romain a commencé à s'affaiblir
ces réserves d'or se sont asséchés on
est alors entré dans une période longue
de pratiquement 1000 ans avant qu'on ne
se remette véritablement exploiter l'or
mais de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
près du berceau de la pièce d'or l'
empire romain orientale ou byzance
prospère sous sa nouvelle religion le
christianisme ainsi que grâce à une
monnaie forte également faite d'or
au début du 4e siècle après jésus-christ
l'empereur constantin de byzance et met
une pièce d'or qui va circuler est
restée la même pendant 700 ans
le bep vente devient la monnaie la plus
courante au monde et restera la plus
longuement utilisé dans toute l'histoire
[Musique]
la capitale de l'empiré byzantin et
constantinople aujourd'hui istanbul
comme sarr 10 elle se situe au carrefour
des grandes routes commerciales
internationales
constantinople faisait figure de point
d'intersection idéal entre l'europe du
nord la russie les steppes et la
méditerranée entre notre asie et notre
europe actuelle au 10ème siècle à
millions de personnes y vivent autant
qu'à rome à son apogée
constantinople s'enrichit grâce au
commerce qui anime ses rues ses
empereurs successifs affichent leur
richesse en se faisant construire de
somptueux palais aux coupoles dorées
mais le succès de la capitale n'est pas
sans éveiller des jalousies déjà une
rivale s'apprête à lui livrer une âpre
bataille en vue de rafler les immenses
bénéfices dégagés par les échanges est
ouest un nouvel empire voit le jour en
europe les pieds dans la vase
il joue son va-tout sur le commerce
maritime et sur l'or durant le moyen-âge
à court d'argent
on rassemble illégalement des copeaux
d'or en limant le bord des pièces
c'est un crime passible de la peine
capitale aux heures les plus sombres du
moyen-âge une ville va renaître des
cendres de l'empiré romain
une cité lacustre béni pour sa
géographie
[Musique]
sa région méditerranéenne et son
littoral peser d'un poids important dans
le monde
star venise se situer en place entre
c'était une plaque tournante des
échanges notamment industrielles entre
l'est comme le chine et l'ouest
c'était aussi une plateforme pour le
commerce avec l'afrique du nord tout
aussi civilisé
si d'autres nations ont pris de l'essor
grâce à leur conquête les vénitiens
bâtissent leur empire sur le commerce en
1104 on assiste à un développement
significatif venise ouvre son fameux
arsenal et commence à construire des
navires
cette activité véritablement ce qui a
marqué la fondation de son empire
grande pionnière de la chaîne
d'assemblage venise devient le haut lieu
de la construction navale en
méditerranée sur le plus vaste chantier
d'europe
elle construit la plus imposante flotte
que le monde ait connu
ces négociants samar dans tous les ports
du monde et se taille la part du lion
dans le commerce fructueux des soie et
des épices orientales venise bénéficier
de ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui une
balance commerciale excédentaire
autrement dit elle exportait plus
qu'elle n'apportait et la différence lui
permettait d'amasser de l'or les rois et
les empereurs européens étaient
constamment endetté envers les banquiers
florentins et vénitien et compris
jusqu'à henry 8
même les chevaliers français cherchant
pour leur quatrième croisade un passage
vers la terre sainte vont jusqu'à se
traîner au pied des vénitiens les miled
watch ndaw est en 1202 les croisés sont
arrivés ensemble à venir mais il n'avait
pas les moyens de payer la somme
d'argent convenu ils sont contraints de
s'en remettre un homme faible de 88 ans
le dirigeant des vénitiens était un
personnage fascinant
il s'appelait anne rigaud dan doyle et
c'était le doj où le duc ou encore le
gouverneur de venise et il était aveugle
dandolo saisi au vol l'occasion qui se
présente il accepte de fournir les
navires à condition que ce soit lui qui
tiennent la barre de la croisade
si les chevaliers ont l'ambition d'une
'guerre sainte' dandolo lui complotent
une véritable vendetta commercial de
venise les vénitiens ils se sont par
conséquent retrouver en tête de la
quatrième croisade ont décidé non pas de
naviguer jusqu'en palestine pour livrer
bataille afin de libérer les royaumes
chrétiens mais plutôt de s'arrêter à
constantine à près d'un millénaire des
échanges commerciaux ont fait de
constantinople une capitale aussi riche
que bell
pour dandolo la ville est une horreur
c'est simplement une rivale dans ses
affaires avec lorient si l'on était pas
une question des changes seulement avec
la syrie ou la palestine celle ci se
trouvait au bout de la route de la soie
et le commerce qui s'étendait bien au
delà jusqu'en chine était extrêmement
rentable pas étonnant donc qu'elle ait
fini par s'affronter tenté par leur part
du butin
les croisés français se joignent aux
vénitiens pour assiéger la ville
celle ci doit sa chute en 12 cents 0 4
aux massacres et aux pillages perpétrés
[Musique]
est la ville la plus riche au monde
1900 endurant avait échappé aux
conquêtes et avait baigné dans
l'opulence était tout à coup mise à sac
les vénitiens ont fait des affaires
pendant des siècles ils savent où
exactement dénicher le magot y diderot
la grande cathédrale de sainte sophie
les églises des saints apôtres ainsi que
d'autres lieux de culte ont été saccagés
par les chrétiens d'occident l'une des
plus importantes collections de trésors
de byzance ou constantinople se trouve
aujourd'hui à venise notamment dans sa
cathédrale saint-marc alors qu'on se
taillant morceau l' empire byzantin
les vénitiens s'empare des ports
dynamiques des côtes est du bassin
faisant de venise un empire hors pair
dans le monde
l'année 12 104 voix la naissance d'une
puissance maritime sans précédent une
puissance jamais égalé dans l'europe de
l'époque
venise préfigure aussi à nouveau type
dans pire elle est une mine d'initiative
économique reposant sur la navigation
les échanges et l'or
t'endors que partout en europe ce sont
les vénitiens eux mêmes qui décident de
son prix
chaque matin et chaque après midi un son
de cloche annonçait le début d'une
séance spécifique sur le rialto et
visant à fixer les prix et les
commerçants qui étaient venus avec de
l'or ou de l'argent ou bien qui voulait
en acheter participé à cette séance
il revient logiquement à venise de
frapper la monnaie officielle
leduc a vénitien devient ainsi pour les
quatre siècles qui suivent la devise en
vigueur dans tout le bassin et même au
delà ce perso si on trouvait des ducats
dans des endroits très éloignées
jusqu'en inde et même jusqu'en chine
c'est vous dire le prestige dont jouit
c'est cette monnaie sur la surface du
globe
tel qu'il était alors connu aussi
longtemps que la méditerranée demeure le
centre du monde
venise en est l'épicentre
l'ironie du sort veut que ce soit en
italien christophe colomb qui destitue
venise de son rôle de leader commercial
avec le soutien des monarques espagnols
colons s'embarquant 14 192 pour la plus
audacieuse des routes vers les richesses
de l'est
il lève les voiles vers l'ouest
tout le monde visaient le sud en
contournant l'afrique ce que l'on a dit
non on va plutôt par là ce sera bien
plus rapide
les gens l'ont écouté parce qu'il était
convaincu de trouver de l'or en arrivant
rapidement il se disait que le premier
pays à financer son expédition serait
ensuite le pays à pouvoir se servir en
or et en richesse qui ferait de lui le
maître du monde s'y colle on ne touchera
jamais taire en asie le nouveau monde
qu'il découvre s'avère riche en or
suffisamment pour faire des espagnols
justement les maîtres du monde
et comme venise l'espagne sera également
amené à survivre à son âge d'or à la fin
du xvième siècle d'autres pays ont
occupé le devant de la scène
essentiellement en parvenant à devancé
les espagnols sur les océans
l'europe du nord en particulier la
hollande et bien entendu l'angleterre
qui est progressivement devenu l' empire
britannique au cours des deux ou trois
siècles suivants le centre du monde se
déplaçant vers l'atlantique
ces terres voit naître des empires
comparable à celui de venise ainsi
londres devient bientôt le nouveau géant
des échanges et se dote d'un nouveau
marché de l'or ainsi que d'une toute
nouvelle monnaie officielle au même
titre que le duc avait dit 'tiens à son
époque les deux devises que sont le
guinée et le souverain anglais au cours
dans le monde entier entre 1700 et 1900
mais outre atlantique
l'histoire de laure s'apprête à vivre un
tout nouveau chapitre une nation
révolutionnaire redéfinit le concept
même de l'argent et son rapport avec
l'or
[Musique]
le pal adorent au retable de la
basilique saint-marc à venise est ornée
de joyau inestimable pays à
constantinople est serti dans un énorme
bloc d'or au début du 19e siècle les
tout jeunes états unis souffre d'un
retard économique leur expansion ne
s'avère possible khaled d'espèces en
petite monnaie
au début des années 1800 notre pays
était sous développés on apportait plus
de marchandises et de services qu'on en
exportait par conséquent nos espèces
monnayer ou métalliques puisqu'elles
sont frappés dans le métal partait vers
l'étranger on se retrouvait donc avec
très peu de monnaie les banques devront
faire face grâce à une solution
révolutionnaire le papier monnaie ou
monnaies fiduciaires elle émettait leur
billet chaque banque avait ses propres
modèles avec leurs propres valeurs les
banques diffuser ses billets sous la
forme de prêts puisqu'on avait
l'assurance qu'il serait accepté les
gens pouvaient les dépenser et
éventuellement les rapporter au guichet
et les échanger contre leur valeur en or
la première expérience américaine avec
le papier-monnaie a lieu pendant sa
révolution
mais imprimé par le gouvernement sans la
moindre garantie de contrepartie la
monnaie s'avère sans valeur ces nouveaux
billets en revanche sont avalisés par
lors que détient la banque
ils sont remboursables contre de l'or
durant les décennies qui précède la
guerre civile
les billets émis par les banques privées
représentent la mener la plus couramment
utilisée en amérique
les gens affluent en masse aux
etats-unis dans la guerre civile et
l'économie se développe rapidement
l'offre en métaux précieux comme l'or et
l'argent par contre ne suis pas
forcément les banques augmentent donc
l'offre de monnaie le problème est que
les banques développent trop cette offre
la valeur nominale des billets en
circulation dépasse de loin leur contre
valeur en or
et les sauveteurs le système monétaire
en vigueur à l'époque était mal perçue
on ne disposait que de temps en or et en
argent et on émettait pourtant des
billets pour deux à trois fois la valeur
de l'or en réserve des banques douteuses
ne se gênait pas pour mettre en
circulation du papier monnaie qu'elles
étaient peu ou pas sûr de garantir pour
peu que les détenteurs se présente en
même temps afin de convertir en or leur
billet les banques couler c'est ce qui
arrive à des centaines d'entre elles au
cours des années 1830
ce n'est qu'en 1848 que l'amérique
parvient à se libérer de sa camisole
économique lors de californie a
véritablement placer les états unis au
rang d' entités économiques d'envergure
internationale lors californien devient
le sens de l'économie américaine ce
navire est l'une des artères par
lesquels il transite
deux fois par mois sur 43 voyage le
paquebot central america convoi lors
californien vers new york en est et 1857
wall street attend avec impatience
l'arrivée de la 44e traversée il y avait
à l'époque ce qu'on appelle maintenant
une récession économique
ce n'était pas une dépression pour
autant mais des problèmes avait démarré
en juillet et en août
l'argent banquet il y avait eu des
faillites et le marché était très tendue
on attendait donc une grande quantité
d'or en provenance de san francisco pour
regonfler les marchés financier new
yorkais
outre ces 19 tonnes d'or le central
america transporte 500 passagers pour la
plupart des chercheurs d'or rentrant
chez eux avec leur bas de laine durement
gagné
[Musique]
la nuit du 12 septembre à 260 km au
large des côtes de caroline le centre à
l'amérique a traversé un ouragan
après trois jours passés sous des pluies
diluviennes assailli dans les vagues sa
chaudière submergées il perd tout
contrôle
c'est passager abandonnent leurs espoirs
comme ils quittent le navire en y
laissant leurs lourds de fortune
au tout dernier moment lors leur est
apparu comme inutile il ya des
témoignages sur des gens jetant leur or
depuis leurs cabines de luxe le
déversant précipitamment sur le pont
lors c'est lourd
ce n'est pas ça qui allait leur porter
secours une fois dans l'eau et justement
dès qu'il réalisait il devait sauter
dans l'eau lors devenait tout à coup
quelque chose dont il fallait se
débarrasser
lorsque le navire a sombré avec à bord
ce qui représentait à l'époque les
millions de dollars au nord la panique
qui s'en est suivi a généré une
véritable récession
ce fut le comble lors couler les banques
de la côte est la panique et la
récession économique de 1857 se sont
sérieusement aggravées
parce que le véritable moteur du pays
ses torts qu'on attendait de californie
s'était brutalement volatilisé aussi
longtemps que l'économie repose sur l'or
celui ci continue de menacer la nation
toute entière la guerre civile éclate
la bataille fait rage sur l'or le papier
est l'argent
[Musique]
l'ironie du sort veut que l'un des
navires avoir recueilli des rescapés du
central america porte le nom du roi
légendaire qui aimait se couvrir de
poussière d'or eldorado le 12 avril 1861
un premier coup de canon plonge
l'amérique dans la guerre civile ainsi
que dans une crise économique provoquée
par une pénurie d'argent liquide
la plupart de l'argent utilisé aux états
unis avant la guerre civile circule sous
la forme de billets émis par les banques
privées au début de cette guerre
on est même en présence de milliers de
billets différents les gens pouvaient
sortir de leur portefeuille un billet de
la state bank de tchin tchin ati un
autre venant de la miller merchant bank
à new york il y en avait d'innombrables
variétés ses billets peuvent être
rapportés auprès de leur banque
émettrice afin d'y être rachetées contre
les pièces d'or ce jusqu'à un certain
jour d'avril
à force hunter le gouvernement fédéral
doit faire face à une guerre difficile
chaque nouvelle journée de 1861 donne le
sentiment que cette guerre va encore
s'éterniser écouter davantage
pressé de trouver de quoi financer la
guerre le gouvernement emprunte de l'or
auprès des banques privées aussi celle
ci se retrouve-t-elle avec des réserves
insuffisantes pour garantir leur papier
monnaie la conséquence est une crise
dramatique
tous les billets ont tout à coup
pratiquement perdu leur valeur parce que
les banques ont été obligés de mettre un
terme à leurs compensations en or il
n'ya pas assez d'or et l'amérique ne
parvient pas à gérer à la fois son
économie et la guerre
mais un député new yorkais elle bridge
parle ding sort du lot en proposant une
solution radicalement nouvelle il avait
été banquier auparavant et il a concocté
l'idée de mettre en circulation un
billet fédéral qu'on appellerait le
billet vert ou dollars contrairement aux
billets des banques privées le dollar
n'est pas échangeables contre de l'or il
faut bien comprendre que jusqu'il ya
environ 100 ans tout autre chose que de
l'or était essentiellement considéré
comme un billet à ordre
c'est à dire une promesse de payer mes
deux pays en or c'est la première fois
depuis la constitution du pays qu'on se
retrouve avec une monnaie fiduciaire qui
n'a ni argent ni or derrière elle mais
qui est tout de même une monnaie légale
émises par le gouvernement fédéral un
simple tour de manivelle sur la presse
typographique met en oeuvre un tout
nouveau concept un bout de papier créé
de la valeur parce que le gouvernement
des états-unis en a ainsi décidé le
billet en lui-même ne représentait rien
mais c'était bien de l'argent par
ordonnance du congrès c'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'argent par décret un
véritable bouleversement dans la vie des
américains à la fin de la guerre
le gouvernement a mis en circulation
pour quelque 400 millions de dollars en
billets verts
1 $ en billets verts et qui vaut un
dollar or en théorie seulement
en pratique non le problème est que les
valeurs bouger constamment on avait
d'une part l'or dont la valeur dépend
des de la demande de sa production dans
les mines des échanges commerciaux avec
l'étranger et on n'avait d'autre part le
billet vert dont la masse en circulation
était décidée par le congrès le problème
était donc le suivant comment rendre
possible échange d'or avec le billet
vert on a donc créé un marché spécial à
new york ap les salles de l'or à
l'instar des banquiers vénitien les
agents de change fixe quotidiennement le
prix de l'or à savoir le nombre de
dollars billets nécessaires pour acheter
des dollars
or cette simple équation inspire l'une
des plus célèbres escroquerie de
l'histoire américaine perpétré par un
duo de requins de la finance de l'âge
d'or
jim fisc le banquier haut en couleurs de
l'époque et jay gould anne ancienne
employée d'épicerie de campagne devenu
magna du chemin de fer jay gould team
fisc venait juste de faire parler d'eux
il avait joué un rôle prédominant dans
une énorme bataille financière à wall
street sur la prise de contrôle de la
compagnie de chemins de fer et riz alors
l'une des plus importantes dans le pays
ils ont été corrompre des législateurs à
new york
ils ont soudoyé des juges aussi un
moment ils se sont même retrouvés en
bateau sur la rivière hudson et ils
fuyaient vers le new-jersey avec tous
leurs billets au printemps 1869
ghoul défisc commencent à échafauder une
arnaque encore plus audacieuse il s'agit
de s'accaparer le marché de l'or
diaboliquement simple le principe
consiste à profiter de la loi de l'offre
et de la demande
en d'autres termes plus ils achètent
d'or - iliad offre par conséquent la
demande augmente en même temps que le
prix se met à grimper
et lorsque le prix de l'or a
suffisamment montée ghoul défisc vendent
alors tous et empoche au passage de
pactole malheureusement oui réussir ce
genre de coups dans la salle de l'or il
fallait d'abord prendre le contrôle de
la politique du gouvernement
le gouvernement fédéral détenait quelque
chose comme 100 fois l'or en circulation
dans l'économie privée
occasionnellement le gouvernement vend
ses surplus d'or faisant ainsi baisser
le prix du métal jaune
gould et fisc doivent donc s'efforcer de
maintenir lors du gouvernement hors du
marché mais ulysses grant vient
d'arriver au pouvoir et personne ne sait
encore quelle va être sa politique
fiscale
ils ont donc décidé d'essayer de prendre
le contrôle de la politique des finances
du président grant
ils ont d'abord accompagné lors d'un
voyage à boston à bord d'un paquebot
dont l'un d'entre eux était propriétaire
qui se sont assis avec lui et ils lui
ont parlé du billet vert de l'or mais
grant les déçoit il n'a aucune intention
de geler le marché de l'or sans se
décourager
ghoul défisc décide de poursuivre
l'escroquerie il place une taupe au
ministère des finances
offre un pot-de-vin au beau frère du
président
aimante ouvertement en déclarant aux
journalistes de telle sorte que wall
street l'entendent que grant ne vendra
pas d'or
leur plan fonctionne à merveille tout au
long de l'été 1869
le prix de l'or grimpe régulièrement
pour atteindre à la fin du mois de
septembre la valeur de 160 dollars en
billets verts pour 100 dollars or mais
grant déjouer le complot
lorsqu'il prend connaissance d'une
lettre écrite par son beau-frère en
faveur de good good est parti voir ses
courtiers en coulisses pour leur
demander de commencer à vendre l'or
tranquillement c'est à dire que alors qu
une frénésie prend possession du marché
bull devant c'est précisément à ce
moment que grant donne l'ordre au
ministère des finances de se défaire de
4 millions de dollars en or pour en
faire baisser le prix
lorsqu'on a appris la nouvelle ça a été
la panique immédiatement tout le monde
s'est mis à revendre désespérément sont
l'or et les prix ont chuté
le 24 septembre 1869 et surnommé
vendredi noir
en dégringolant le prix de l'or a balayé
des milliers de spéculateurs gould et
fils que moore ont aussi riches qu'ils
seront maudits pour la crise dont ils
sont à l'origine
et pour les vies qu'ils ont détruites à
l'image de la catastrophe du central
america ce vendredi noir rappelle au
monde que les économies qui s'appuie sur
l'or demeure toujours à sa merci
s'est demandé comment contenir la masse
monétaire en circulation
puisqu'elle dépend des elle-même de la
force incontrôlable de l'or le monde
cependant n'est pas près d' apprendre à
se passer de l'or d'autant plus que les
grande ruée vers l'or qui ont eu lieu en
amérique en australie et en afrique du
sud continuent d'alimenter le flot de
métal précieux qui coule jusqu'aux hôtel
de la monnaie pour la première fois de
l'histoire
l'or était la pièce qui circulait entre
les millions de poches des gens à
travers le moins on ne le trouvait pas
dans la salle des coffres des banques
centrales
ni même à l'époque vraiment utilisé en
bijouterie
c'était au contraire un moyen de
paiement courant pour les achats
quotidiens ou encore la pièce cadeau
qu'on offrait aux petits fils pour noël
comme par exemple un souverain en or au
début du 20e siècle
la plupart des pays sont passés à
l'étalon or grâce aux pièces d'or ainsi
qu'aux papier-monnaie compensable en or
les beaux jours de l'étalon or ne dure
cependant pas plus d'une génération
[Musique]
viens d'abord la première guerre
mondiale jusque là la plus ruineuse de
l'histoire en mettant à sec les réserves
d'or
elle exclut la plus grande partie de
l'europe du standard fixé
arrivent ensuite la fameuse grande
dépression par un samedi morose de mars
1933 la nation la plus riche du monde
est sur le point de basculer dans la
faillite des citoyens américains se sont
mis à fulminer contre les banques du
pays pour que celles-ci reprennent leurs
billets contre de l'or en une seule
semaine 15 % des pièces d'or
disparaissent de la circulation
c'est le pire cauchemar que puisse faire
un banquier voir tous ces déposants
retirer en même temps leur argent
plus de 5000 banques font faillite à
travers le pays
les autres demeurent suspendues à un fil
entre survie et effondrement
le soir de son investiture roosevelt
invoque ses prérogatives utilisable en
temps de guerre pour fermer toutes les
banques moins de vingt quatre heures
plus tard il ratifie une loi retirant
l'amérique de l'étalon or
au nom des états unis je décide de
retirer les pièces en or de la
circulation
on a retiré de la circulation selon le
décret du président roosevelt les pièces
en or les gens qui en théorie they dans
les tiroirs de leurs buffets dans leurs
poches etc ont été invités à les
rapporter sauf celles reconnues comme
ayant une valeur de collection aussi
lorsque les banques rouvrent une semaine
plus tard les dépôts sont à nouveau
supérieurs aux retraits
la crise est passé l'or ne circulent
plus en tant que devise la seule monnaie
légale est faite de cuivre de nickel
d'argent et de papier au lieu de frapper
des pièces d'or
la plupart des gouvernements stocke
désormais le métal jaune en bar afin de
garantir la valeur des billets qu'ils
impriment un dollar d'or équivaut à tant
de dollars papier néanmoins l'éternel
problème subsiste la demande de monnaie
de vence l'offre d'or c'est toujours la
même rengaine à savoir si ce truc de fou
allez continuer à diriger l'économie ou
bien si les gens allaient enfin pouvoir
la gérer comme il s'en sentait capable
cette question va trouver une réponse
définitive dans le sillage d'une seconde
guerre mondiale encore plus dévastatrice
que la première à leur apogée en 1949
les etats unis détiennent la moitié de
tous lors jamais exploité dans
l'histoire soit pratiquement 22 mille
tonnes alors que le monde s'extirpe
difficilement de la grande dépression
une nouvelle crise s'avance à grands pas
celles ci menacent la civilisation tout
entière adolf hitler prend le pouvoir
alors que l'allemagne est encore
chancelante de sa défaite dans la
première guerre mondiale ses réserves
d'or sont vides et sa monnaie sans
valeur
ayant promis de rendre au pays sa gloire
initial hitler entreprend de
reconstruire l'empiré germanique
pour ce faire il lui faut de l'or
il est essentiel de comprendre que les
réserves d'or de l'allemagne en 1939 ne
sont pas énormes
environ 200 millions de dollars et
qu'elle en était déjà largement engagé
notamment dans la construction de la
machine de guerre allemande
par ailleurs le pays ne peut plus
acheter de produits manufacturés à
l'étranger ni de matière première de
base
avec son reich marks trop faible
sa seule alternative reste l'or
aussi au fur et à mesure qu'elles
marchent sur l'europe l'armée allemande
qui au passage les réserves d'or des
nations en 1938 la tchécoslovaquie avec
ses 30 millions de dollars en or en 1939
la pologne avec 85 millions de dollars
en or en réalité ça a commencé en 1938
avec lancelot ce en autriche
ils ont d'abord pris lors des
autrichiens puis en 1939
ils se sont emparés des réserves
tchèques en finissant d'occuper la
tchécoslovaquie et au début de la guerre
chaque fois qu'ils se rendent maîtres
d'un pays il empilait lors la plupart du
butin d'hitler est stocké dans les
chambres fortes de la reichsbank à
berlin
mais le vent commence à tourner pour ce
reich qui doit durer mille ans les
bombardements intensifs menés jour et
nuit par les forces alliées détruisent
systématiquement la machine de guerre
d'hitler en la frappant au coeur c'est à
dire en anéantissant les infrastructures
industrielles
elle mène bâti sur de l'or volé
le 3 février 1945 plus de 900
bombardiers alliés lâche près de 2300
tonnes de bombes de ce berlin
la ville est réduite à l'état de cendres
et de ruines la reichsbank est
pratiquement détruite en février 1945 ce
qui restait des réserves d'or à la
reichsbank a probablement été chargés à
bord de camions par des prisonniers sans
doute français est acheminée jusqu'à
merker au sud de l'allemagne
ce printemps 1945 la troisième armée du
général patton s'avance sur l'allemagne
comme un mastodonte à le 4 avril
elle entre dans la ville de mercoeur des
rumeurs circulent sur une cargaison
secrète parvenues récemment de berlin et
qui auraient été dissimulées tout près
de là dans une ligne de potassium
par curiosité plusieurs gi's décide de
descendre man l enquête
à leur sortie du monde charge 800 mètres
plus bas il tombe nez à nez sur une
énorme porte en acier
on envoie un message à patton que
faut-il faire
la réponse de patton fait sauter la
porte
le génie militaire s'apprêtait à
souffler la porte quelqu'un a réalisé
qu'un demi bâtons de dynamite suffisait
pour faire sauter le mur juste à côté
d'elle sans avoir à s'en faire pour la
chambre forte dans la salle repose plus
de sept mille sacs soigneusement empilés
ce que les américains trouvent à
l'intérieur est tellement incroyable que
trois hommes parmi les plus puissants du
monde veulent le voir de leurs propres
yeux
george patton son supérieur bradley
ainsi que eisenhower commandant suprême
des forces alliées en europe le gratin
s'est déplacé pour une scène hors du
commun
plus de 8000 barres d'or sous forme de
lingots 2005 de reich marks en or de
livres anglaises de francs français et
de pièces américaines 2,20 dollars hors
et des centaines de sacs de pièces d'or
provenant d'autres pays
en s'avançant vers le fond de la mine
patton découvre la cage d'un sinistre
butin tout l'arrière de la chambre était
constitué de biens qui avaient été
volées aux victimes des camps de
concentration il y avait là un
empilement de valises remplies d'argent
tri d'alliance de dents en or chaque sac
caisse ou mal avait été inventoriés avec
soin estampillé d'une étiquette marqué
mâles meurent mais le maire était
l'officier ss allemands qui effectué les
allers retours avec les camps de
concentration pour ramasser tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient comme dans nord
alliance montre en or afin de les
acheminer vers berlin
au cours de la guerre il avait fait
comme ça au moins 77 livraisons
contenant le fruit de son pillage
l'actif a portés au compte de mes
demeures ce chiffre alors à plus d'un
million de dollars américains
aujourd'hui cette somme dépasserait le
milliard mais cette découverte n'est
encore que la partie visible de
l'iceberg
à la fin de la guerre les allemands
avaient pillé pour environ 580 millions
de dollars en or à travers les pays
occupés là dessus on estime à une valeur
de 450 millions de dollars lors
transféré pendant la guerre vers la
suisse ainsi que vers d'autres pays en
1946 on confie cette heure à une
commission internationale chargée de
chiffrer les dommages aux victimes de
l'holocauste
l'excédent est remis à une commission
alliés qui le redistribue aux nations
volée
l'europe est dévastée et se relève
péniblement du second conflit mondial
les etats-unis apparaissent alors comme
le pays le plus riche de l'histoire pour
pouvoir reconstruire leur économie les
nation déchirée par la guerre sont
contraintes d'acheter des dollars
leur mode de paiement reste l'or en
conséquence les réserves d'or des états
unis montent en flèche
la plus grosse part est ainsi stocker 5
niveaux sous manhattan dans les chambres
fortes de la réserve fédérale
à l'époque il y avait dans les sous sols
de manhattan probablement près d'un
quart ou du tiers de tout l'or extrait
au fond des mines
s'appuyant sur une telle quantité d'or
le dollar devient la devise la plus
forte du monde les pays règlent leurs
dettes en dollars et les gouvernements
peuvent échanger leurs dollars pour de
l'or
à l'instar du bénin et du cac le dollar
est l'espèce sonnante et trébuchante
deux décennies plus tard les économies
des pays européens sont remise d'aplomb
c'est au tour de l'amérique de se
saigner avec sa ruineuse guerre du
vietnam
alors que l'europe à nouveau prospère
revend à son tour de plus en plus de
dollars au trésor américain
les réserves en or du pays
s'affaiblissent la confiance dans le
dollar tout puissant s'effondre les
etats unis font face à la pire crise
économique depuis la grande dépression
le président nixon va y répondre par une
solution radicale il cesse d'accepter le
dollar contre de l'or ce que roosevelt a
commencé nixon le termine auront
définitivement le lien qui unit ces
papiers monnaies et or désormais seule
la confiance est susceptible de garantir
la valeur de l'argent
à partir du moment où nixon a coupé le
cordon ombilical une bonne fois pour
toutes
les etats unis se sont retrouvés bien
plus libre qu'avant pour prendre des
décisions économiques
le simple trait de plume de nixon suffi
à renverser un pilier économique
érigé en libye plus de deux mille ans
auparavant
dans nos économies actuelle même la
monnaie fiduciaire devient peu à peu
obsolète
grâce à l'ère digitale de new york à
tokyo des transactions financières
impliquant jusqu'à plusieurs milliards
de dollars ne s'effectue plus par chèque
ni par transfert de métaux précieux mais
par un simple acheminement informatique
de chiffres l'argent est devenu un
concept vous n'entrez pas dans votre
banque en annonçant je veux voir mon
argent parce qu'on va vous regarder d'un
air déconcerté en se demandant de quoi
vous parlez
par contre on va vous imprimer un relevé
de compte et vous explique gentiment
voilà votre argent
si le monde à utiliser les pièces d'or
pendant plus de deux mille ans le papier
monnaie n'est resté en cours qu environ
200 ans on en est arrivé doucement au
point où l'argent est devenu une idée
abstraite alors que nos chambres fortes
sont toujours pleines d'or la question
est de savoir ce qu'on en fait c'est
juste de l'or sans rapport avec unité
d'informations enregistrées sur mon
compte par ma banque ou apparaissant sur
mon relevé de carte de crédit ou encore
dans ma convention de prêt étudiant
c'est devenu simplement une marchandise
ça pourrait aussi bien être une cuve de
pétrole ou un tanker transportant de
l'essence ou même une pile de pneus
c'est juste un objet ce serait
mais pour les pays en voie de
développement qui ne disposent pas de
cartes de crédit et où l'argent ne
représentent parfois pas plus que la
valeur du bout de papier sur lequel il
est imprimé rien ne vaut l'or dans les
zones rurales du moyen-orient d'asie et
du sous continent indien
l'or demeure un moyen des changes parmi
les plus courants et les plus liquides
parce que justement c'est de l'argent
c'est resté la toute première forme de
monnaie des changes ayant existé voilà
pourquoi les rois et les reines
d'angleterre le convoitait voilà
pourquoi venise est devenue le centre
puissant des échanges commerciaux
voilà pourquoi elle s'est déplacée
jusqu'à constantinople pour sont
accaparés davantage l'or est resté
important parce que c'est de l'argent